das familienfoto das wollen wir uns
nämlich einmal anschauen das ist ja wir
sehen hier wirklich die ganze familie
wurde von seiner tochter glaube ich als
erstes england als erstes getötete
familie ist groß wir sehen ja er hat es
geschafft und die ganze familie ist bei
ihm
und das ist wirklich wir haben vorhin
mit der kollegin nina schenk darüber
geredet dass die familie traum so eng
beieinander ist damit zeigt ja auch joe
biden dass auch seine familie sehr eng
ist steht immer hinter ihm seine frau
die er als first lady jetzt trotzdem
noch lehrerin bleiben möchte was auch
faszinierend ist es wird relativ viel
sein was in ihrem zeitplan drinsteht ich
finde das super also über trumps familie
und den zusammenhalt ich glaube die
werden vom geld zusammengehalten ist es
relativ einfach solange jeder irgendwie
ein stück vom kuchen ab krieg sind die
zusammen fertig aus wir haben eine
nichte die er hat nicht genug geld
bekommen mary jane die ist dann ganz
woanders unterwegs gestern keine
einigung mehr also bei familie trump ist
es glaube ich eine ganz andere
geschichte bei den beiden hat man
wirklich den eindruck dass er eine ganz
große wärme herrscht einfach weil sie
auch dieses traurige schicksal irgendwie
einig die bahn hat mal gesagt sie wusste
zu dem zeitpunkt als wo der sohn von joe
biden an einem hirntumor staat nicht
mehr wie sie es überhaupt schaffen soll
zu lächeln wie sie es schaffen soll
aufzustehen und diese familie hat
dadurch dass sie so viel leid erfahren
hat eben auch zusammenhalt ganz
intensiven zusammenhalt gelernt und das
streit für mich dieses foto aus die
chips sind in meinen augen damit nicht
vergleichbar die müssen wir dann in so
eine badewanne voller dollarnoten packen
dann würde das wahrscheinlich auch
zusammenhalt aus stein die idee mit der
badewanne ja die typischen foto kulissen
oder dass man dann in so einem
badewannen swimmingpool voller geld
liegt das stimmt also dass auf jeden
fall ein ganz anderes foto ein
familienfoto wie das eigentlich glaube
ich jeder von uns zu hause machen könnte
also nah dran an den leitstand und das
tolle ist ja nie benannt nach seiner
verstorbenen tochter naomi dem alter von
einem jahr mit seiner frauen 172 bei
diesem schrecklichen autounfall ums
leben kam und nahm seine enkelin ist 26
jahre alt und traut sich eben auch auf
twitter was zu sagen sie hat mal den
damaligen
sprecher von obama ich immer dass hier
irgendwo notierte er wird als schrott
gesagt dieser job wird in microphone ja
hat sie getötet nachdem er ihren pop wie
sie joe biden kritisiert hat also sie
hat selber columbia law studiert ist ein
wahnsinnig er warnte die schlaue frau
und hat glaube ich auch in dieser
kampagne viel gebracht aber zeigt eben
auch dass diese familie ist nicht
zusammenhält und dieses foto strahlt
irre viel aus ich kann mir vorstellen
dass da ist natürlich jetzt sagt man es
vielleicht nicht gestellt ist sondern
das so zu hause in delaware sich die in
den armen liegen und sich freuen und das
ist natürlich eine menschlichkeit die
wollen wir erzählen im weißen haus
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren